let's hear from a few more people via
the Discord which you can find at
davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to go next to
Jeremy from Suffolk in the UK Jeremy
welcome
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hey um sorry I just joined you kind of
caught me off guard
um I don't necessarily think I have a
like a question per se I guess I just I
know the election's happening right now
and it's it's going much better than
what we thought but I still just have
such frustrations with um
the younger generation and um my my kind
stems from um a military I'm stationed
here in the UK and uh I'm gonna use it
with like 250 people and in my section I
supervise 40 plus people and like I
asked around seeing kind of guarding
interest of who's going to register if
there's been a mailing about like none
of them none of them
had zero interest in getting out to vote
and like making their voices heard and
the most frustrating one was I have a
trans person in my fights and um when I
asked her if she was going to vote she
kind of gave me like a shoulder shrug
and I think qualitative for old people
it was super frustrating just to kind of
deal with that kind of mentality yeah
yeah which of course is a
self-fulfilling process right if young
people say I'm not going to get involved
because politics is for older people
they're basically seeding that politics
is for the older people who choose to
vote it's it's a self-fulfilling endless
loop
right uh the one thing I wanted to say
to her was you know there are two
political sides in our country right now
and one of those sides would attack or
not even attack you but like really
I I guess yeah attack you in the way you
choose to live your life and by you not
voting that kind of just like allows
that to continue on yep
without a doubt without a doubt uh dip
now is the politic aside from being
apathetic
is it also a right-wing group of people
you know um
so I I really I try to avoid that
conversation mostly because there are
people who are more commensurate as my
rank that I can't have that conversation
with and I will tell you most of them
are more right-leading uh I do think the
the younger crowd is left-leaning but at
the same time I try not to have that
that full discussion because it's it's
not really my place to to kind of
influence how they how they view their
politics uh I can like I can
convincefully try and go out and vote
but uh me kind of expressing my ideas
that's like using my rank and my
positions here to influence them and
that's like I'm not okay with that
inside it's generally okay in the
military understood understood well
Jeremy I appreciate the call thank you
all right thank you all right there's
Jeremy Culligan from the UK quite a
situation he's uh facing there let's go
to uh Chris from Atlanta Chris welcome
to the program
Chris from Atlanta welcome you're on
and last chance for Chris from Atlanta
all right let's go to Aaron from Los
Angeles Aaron from Los Angeles welcome
to the show
hi David I was wondering if you um have
been keeping up with what's been
happening uh uh on with LA City politics
at a local level
um there's been quite a lot that's been
going on in the past month I I really
have not
um so I guess the first thing that
happened was was our um
the city council president had to resign
following a elite audio of a racism
Scandal oh yes I did see that yes
so there was that that occurred and now
it looks like in light of the election
it's Rick Cruz so it might win over
Karen bass and I'm not sure if you know
who recruso is I don't I just have not
been following that race uh yeah um so
he was actually registered as a
republican for uh years before
um switching over to the Democrat I
think around 2020
and um Karen bass is the more
Progressive candidate but in light of
everything that's happening with the
homelessness and everything else it
looks like a lot of people are going
with a more I guess center-right
candidate that's posing as a Democrat
so I yeah sorry
um I guess it's my apologies it was just
uh my question was just like very nice
and uh based around that all right well
yeah I I am uh I apologize that I'm not
as familiar with that race as as maybe
you are but I appreciate you engaging
with it and it's really important that
we all engage with our local races you
know it's like it's it's very
interesting and relevant to follow like
does Doug mastriano become governor of
Pennsylvania fortunately he doesn't
um but for most of us the things that
affect us day to day are local issues
who's the mayor who are the city
councilors what sort of decisions are
being made in our schools Etc so good
for you Aaron for following it all
oh thanks for taking my call my pleasure
there is Aaron from Los Angeles
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping